Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. February 2017 presented an unseasonably warm winter for the residents of Delphi, a small mid-western city in the American state of Indiana. The season was typically marred with freezing cold weather, with the snowy period beginning in early January that could last for several months.
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. February 2017 presented an unseasonably warm winter for the residents of Delphi, a small mid-western city in the American state of Indiana. The season was typically marred with freezing cold weather, with the snowy period beginning in early January that could last for several months.|||我们的节目涉及严肃且常常令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目说明。2017年2月，对于美国印第安纳州中西部小城德尔斐的居民来说，是一个反常暖和的冬天。这个季节通常伴随着刺骨的寒冷，从1月上旬开始的降雪期往往会持续好几个月。
School schools were required to schedule a set amount of days off in anticipation of the snowfall, but the uncharacteristically high temperatures in Delphi that year meant the predetermined snow days had gone unused. As it was compulsory for administrators to close schools down for the accumulated time off regardless of the weather, Delphi's students gained an extra long weekend to that month, beginning on Thursday, February 9, which classes set to resume on Tuesday, the 14th. On the second last day of the short winter break, 13-year-old Abigail Williams packed her belongings in preparation for a sleepover at the home of her best friend, 14-year-old
School schools were required to schedule a set amount of days off in anticipation of the snowfall, but the uncharacteristically high temperatures in Delphi that year meant the predetermined snow days had gone unused. As it was compulsory for administrators to close schools down for the accumulated time off regardless of the weather, Delphi's students gained an extra long weekend to that month, beginning on Thursday, February 9, which classes set to resume on Tuesday, the 14th. On the second last day of the short winter break, 13-year-old Abigail Williams packed her belongings in preparation for a sleepover at the home of her best friend, 14-year-old|||学校原本需要为预期的降雪安排一定数量的假期，但德尔斐当年反常的高温意味着这些预定的雪假没有派上用场。由于管理人员无论天气如何都必须按累积的休假时间关闭学校，德尔斐的学生们在该月获得了一个额外的长周末，从2月9日星期四开始，课程定于14日星期二恢复。在这段短暂寒假的倒数第二天，13岁的阿比盖尔·威廉姆斯收拾好行李，准备去她最好的朋友——14岁的……
Liberty German. The two girls had established a close friendship from a young age and now attended 8th grade together at Delphi Community Middle School. With a bond described as stronger than most, the pair were inseparable. They played alto sax together in the school band, competed on the same volleyball team, and Liberty had recently convinced Abigail to join her on their school's softball team. They both had a love for the outdoors and shared many other interests too, including camping, fishing, riding all-terrain vehicles, and hiking.
Liberty German. The two girls had established a close friendship from a young age and now attended 8th grade together at Delphi Community Middle School. With a bond described as stronger than most, the pair were inseparable. They played alto sax together in the school band, competed on the same volleyball team, and Liberty had recently convinced Abigail to join her on their school's softball team. They both had a love for the outdoors and shared many other interests too, including camping, fishing, riding all-terrain vehicles, and hiking.|||……利伯蒂·日耳曼家过夜。这两个女孩从小就建立了深厚的友谊，现在一起在德尔斐社区中学读八年级。她们的纽带被形容为比大多数人都牢固，两人形影不离。她们在学校乐队里一起吹中音萨克斯，在同一支排球队竞技，利伯蒂最近还说服阿比盖尔加入学校的垒球队。她们两人都热爱户外活动，并且有着许多相同的兴趣，包括露营、钓鱼、骑全地形车和徒步旅行。
Despite their numerous similarities and mutual hobbies, the girls had their own unique qualities. Abigail, known by friends as Abby, was the quieter of the two but was still very sociable. An avid reader with a creative flair, her mother, Anna, remarked that Abigail had more craft than she knew what to do with, and there wasn't a form of art that she hadn't tried. She spent most of her time making an assortment of creations, including rubber band bracelets and beaded jewellery, which she often gifted to her friends. She had also recently begun knitting tiny colourful hats for newborn babies at the local hospital. Liberty, better known as Libby, was the more outgoing of the pair, with a reputation for
Despite their numerous similarities and mutual hobbies, the girls had their own unique qualities. Abigail, known by friends as Abby, was the quieter of the two but was still very sociable. An avid reader with a creative flair, her mother, Anna, remarked that Abigail had more craft than she knew what to do with, and there wasn't a form of art that she hadn't tried. She spent most of her time making an assortment of creations, including rubber band bracelets and beaded jewellery, which she often gifted to her friends. She had also recently begun knitting tiny colourful hats for newborn babies at the local hospital. Liberty, better known as Libby, was the more outgoing of the pair, with a reputation for|||尽管有许多相似之处和共同的爱好，这两个女孩也有各自独特的品质。阿比盖尔被朋友们称为艾比，是两人中较安静的一个但也非常善于社交。她是一个热爱阅读且极具创作天赋的人，她的母亲安娜评价说，阿比盖尔的手工才华多得用不完，几乎没有她没尝试过的艺术形式。她把大部分时间都花在制作各种各样的手工艺品上，包括橡皮筋手链和串珠首饰，她经常把这些作为礼物送给朋友。她最近还开始为当地医院的新生儿织色彩缤纷的小帽子。利伯蒂，也就是大家熟知的莉比，是两人中更外向的一个，以……
being a joker. The Honor Roll student dreamed of becoming a science teacher and had already laid the foundation to achieve her goal by attending several classes at a local university. An enthusiastic athlete, Liberty also participated in many sports, including volleyball, soccer, swimming, and softball. Liberty lived at the home of her grandparents, Mike and Becky Paddy, along with her older sister, 17-year-old Kelsey, and their father, Derek. She often baked batches of cookies for her family, ensuring there were always some left
being a joker. The Honor Roll student dreamed of becoming a science teacher and had already laid the foundation to achieve her goal by attending several classes at a local university. An enthusiastic athlete, Liberty also participated in many sports, including volleyball, soccer, swimming, and softball. Liberty lived at the home of her grandparents, Mike and Becky Paddy, along with her older sister, 17-year-old Kelsey, and their father, Derek. She often baked batches of cookies for her family, ensuring there were always some left|||爱开玩笑而闻名。这位荣誉榜学生梦想成为一名科学老师，并通过在当地一所大学旁听几门课程，为实现自己的目标奠定了基础。作为一名热心的运动员，利伯蒂还参加了许多体育运动，包括排球、足球、游泳和垒球。利伯蒂和祖父母迈克和贝基·帕迪住在一起，还有她17岁的姐姐凯尔西以及他们的父亲德里克。她经常为家人烤几批曲奇饼干，确保总能留下一部分……
over for her grandfather when he returned home from work. On Sunday, February 12th, Abigail and Liberty spent the afternoon in the Paddy's backyard practising their swing in preparation for the upcoming softball season. That night, the pair emptied Abigail's craft box onto Liberty's bedroom floor and stayed up late painting pictures. When they woke up the following morning of Monday, February 13, Liberty's father Derek made the girls a pancake breakfast. The warm weather had persisted, and Abigail and Liberty decided to make the most of it
over for her grandfather when he returned home from work. On Sunday, February 12th, Abigail and Liberty spent the afternoon in the Paddy's backyard practising their swing in preparation for the upcoming softball season. That night, the pair emptied Abigail's craft box onto Liberty's bedroom floor and stayed up late painting pictures. When they woke up the following morning of Monday, February 13, Liberty's father Derek made the girls a pancake breakfast. The warm weather had persisted, and Abigail and Liberty decided to make the most of it|||留给下班回家的爷爷。2月12日星期日，阿比盖尔和利伯蒂在帕迪家的后院度过了整个下午，练习挥棒，为即将到来的垒球赛季做准备。那天晚上，两人把阿比盖尔的手工盒倒在利伯蒂的卧室地板上，熬夜画画。当她们在第二天2月13日星期一早晨醒来时，利伯蒂的父亲德里克为两个女孩做了煎饼早餐。温暖的天气一直在持续，阿比盖尔和利伯蒂决定好好利用它……
by spending the afternoon hiking along one of their favourite walking tracks, the Monon Highbridge Trail. They both shared an interest in photography and aimed to capture some scenic nature shots along the secluded wooded track. Liberty's sister, Kelsey, offered to drive the teens to their hiking destination, and at 1.45pm, she dropped Abigail and Liberty off at the large wooden sign that marked the beginning of the Monon Highbridge Trail. In the early 1980s, the development of a half-mile track known as the Fander's Topath Trail paved
by spending the afternoon hiking along one of their favourite walking tracks, the Monon Highbridge Trail. They both shared an interest in photography and aimed to capture some scenic nature shots along the secluded wooded track. Liberty's sister, Kelsey, offered to drive the teens to their hiking destination, and at 1.45pm, she dropped Abigail and Liberty off at the large wooden sign that marked the beginning of the Monon Highbridge Trail. In the early 1980s, the development of a half-mile track known as the Fander's Topath Trail paved|||在她们最喜欢的步道之一——莫on高桥步道（Monon Highbridge Trail）上徒步度过整个下午。她们两人都对摄影感兴趣，并希望沿着这条僻静的林间小路捕捉一些风景优美的自然照片。利伯蒂的姐姐凯尔西主动提出开车送这几个青少年去徒步目的地，下午1点45分，她把阿比盖尔和利伯蒂放在了标志着莫on高桥步道起点的巨大木牌前。在20世纪80年代初，一条被称为范德托帕斯步道（Fander's Topath Trail）的长达半英里的道路的开发，为……
the way for what would eventually become the Delphi Historic Trails, 10 miles of groomed hiking trails that stretch throughout the town. The trails take visitors past various architectural landmarks, with two miles winding through the town itself, while the remainder curl through the wooded outskirts. Forming an important element of Delphi's identity, the trails provide a popular spot for campers, fishermen, trail bike riders, and hikers. Boaters and kayakers also take to the waterways that line some of the paths. The Monon Highbridge Trail is one of the longest trails in the network, spanning over 1.5 miles,
the way for what would eventually become the Delphi Historic Trails, 10 miles of groomed hiking trails that stretch throughout the town. The trails take visitors past various architectural landmarks, with two miles winding through the town itself, while the remainder curl through the wooded outskirts. Forming an important element of Delphi's identity, the trails provide a popular spot for campers, fishermen, trail bike riders, and hikers. Boaters and kayakers also take to the waterways that line some of the paths. The Monon Highbridge Trail is one of the longest trails in the network, spanning over 1.5 miles,|||最终成为德尔斐历史步道（Delphi Historic Trails）奠定了基础——这是一条长达10英里、维护良好的徒步小径，贯穿整个小镇。这些步道带领游客穿过各种建筑地标，其中两英里蜿蜒穿过小镇本身，其余部分则在树木丛生的郊外盘旋。作为德尔斐身份的重要组成部分，这些步道为露营者、渔民、越野自行车手和徒步旅行者提供了一个受欢迎的场所。划船者和皮划艇爱好者也会前往小路旁的航道。莫on高桥步道是该网络中最长的步道之一，全长超过1.5英里，……
located on the eastern cusp of town near the Delphi Cemetery, its trailhead sits alongside a parking area at a dead-end driveway. A 0.85-mile southeasterly hike leads to an 853-foot-long historic railroad trestle bridge that towers 63 feet above the shallow waters of Deer Creek. It has been out of commission since 1987, with the train tracks and guardrails since removed so that just the wooden railroad planks remain. Despite its remote, rural setting, the Monon Highbridge Trail is frequently traversed by hikers, dogwalkers, and tourists.
located on the eastern cusp of town near the Delphi Cemetery, its trailhead sits alongside a parking area at a dead-end driveway. A 0.85-mile southeasterly hike leads to an 853-foot-long historic railroad trestle bridge that towers 63 feet above the shallow waters of Deer Creek. It has been out of commission since 1987, with the train tracks and guardrails since removed so that just the wooden railroad planks remain. Despite its remote, rural setting, the Monon Highbridge Trail is frequently traversed by hikers, dogwalkers, and tourists.|||位于德尔斐公墓附近的小镇东侧边缘，其步道起点位于一条尽头车道旁的停车场旁边。向东南方向徒步0.85英里，便可到达一座长853英尺的历史悠久的铁路高架栈桥，它高耸于鹿溪（Deer Creek）浅水上方63英尺。自1987年以来，它就一直处于停用状态，铁轨和护栏此后已被拆除，只剩下木制的铁路枕木。尽管其环境偏远而乡村化，但莫on高桥步道依然经常有徒步旅行者、遛狗者和游客穿行。
As the bridge also provides a picturesque backdrop for wedding fatos and high school senior pitchers, it is also a great place to visit. From the drop-off point at the trailhead, Abigail Williams and Liberty Germans set out down the wide, crushed stone path that led to the bridge. Framed by dry fallen leaves and tall, thin trees stripped bare by the winter season, the flat, spacious path was easy to trek, making for a leisurely hike. Eventually, the pair reached the Monon Highbridge, where Liberty stopped for a moment to hold up her smartphone and take a photo of the old, splintered railroad overpass ahead.
As the bridge also provides a picturesque backdrop for wedding fatos and high school senior pitchers, it is also a great place to visit. From the drop-off point at the trailhead, Abigail Williams and Liberty Germans set out down the wide, crushed stone path that led to the bridge. Framed by dry fallen leaves and tall, thin trees stripped bare by the winter season, the flat, spacious path was easy to trek, making for a leisurely hike. Eventually, the pair reached the Monon Highbridge, where Liberty stopped for a moment to hold up her smartphone and take a photo of the old, splintered railroad overpass ahead.|||由于这座桥还为婚礼照片和高中毕业生的照片提供了风景如画的背景，它也是一个游览的好地方。从步道起点的下车点出发，阿比盖尔·威廉姆斯和利伯蒂·日耳曼沿着通往桥梁的宽阔碎石小路出发。在干枯的落叶和被冬季剥光了叶子的又高又细的树木的映衬下，平坦宽敞的小路很容易走，是一次悠闲的徒步旅行。最终，两人到达了莫on高桥，利伯蒂在那里停了一会儿，举起智能手机，给前方破旧、开裂的铁路立交桥拍了张照片。
Wanting to share their adventure with her friends and family via social media, Liberty uploaded the image to her account with picture messaging and a link to the video. The girls continued on, with Liberty leading the way, as Abigail followed close behind. After walking roughly 90 feet, Liberty turned around and took a second photo, this time capturing Abigail in mid-step on the bridge. The candid photo displayed the teenager of the old man, Burgundy Top, blue jeans and black sneakers, with her hands tucked into the pockets of
Wanting to share their adventure with her friends and family via social media, Liberty uploaded the image to her account with picture messaging and a link to the video. The girls continued on, with Liberty leading the way, as Abigail followed close behind. After walking roughly 90 feet, Liberty turned around and took a second photo, this time capturing Abigail in mid-step on the bridge. The candid photo displayed the teenager of the old man, Burgundy Top, blue jeans and black sneakers, with her hands tucked into the pockets of|||为了通过社交媒体与朋友和家人分享她们的冒险经历，利伯蒂将图片上传到她的账号，附带彩信和视频链接。女孩们继续前行，利伯蒂带路，阿比盖尔紧随其后。大约走了90英尺后，利伯蒂转过身拍了第二张照片，这次抓拍到了阿比盖尔在桥上迈步的瞬间。这张抓拍照片展示了这位身穿勃艮第红上衣、蓝色牛仔鞋和黑色运动鞋的年轻女孩，她的双手插在……
the grey sweatshirt she had borrowed from Liberty. With her head slightly lowered, she was positioned in the right foreground of the image, with the bridge stretching behind her against a dense background of barren trees. At 2.07pm, Liberty also took a photo of the old man, Burgundy Top. At 2.07pm, Liberty also posted this picture to her Snapchat account. Less than one hour later, Liberty's father, Derek German, was returning from an afternoon of running errands in the nearby city of Frankfurt and planned on picking the girls
the grey sweatshirt she had borrowed from Liberty. With her head slightly lowered, she was positioned in the right foreground of the image, with the bridge stretching behind her against a dense background of barren trees. At 2.07pm, Liberty also took a photo of the old man, Burgundy Top. At 2.07pm, Liberty also posted this picture to her Snapchat account. Less than one hour later, Liberty's father, Derek German, was returning from an afternoon of running errands in the nearby city of Frankfurt and planned on picking the girls|||她向利伯蒂借来的灰色运动衫的口袋里。她微微垂着头，位于图像的右前景，桥梁在她身后延伸，背景是茂密的贫瘠树木。下午2点07分，利伯蒂还拍了一张身穿勃艮第红上衣的老人的照片。下午2点07分，利伯蒂也将这张照片发布到了她的Snapchat账号上。不到一个小时后，利伯蒂的父亲德里克·日耳曼结束了在附近城市法兰克福一下午的跑腿办事，正准备去接这两个女孩……
up from the Monon Highbridge trail on his way home. Although they hadn't organized the specific meeting time, the trail didn't take long to navigate, and it was presumed the girls would be finished by the time he arrived. As he approached, Derek sent his daughter a text message to let her know he was on his way. At 3.14pm, Derek pulled up at the trailhead parking lot to find that neither of the girls were there. He sent Liberty several follow-up text messages, but received no response, and his calls went unanswered, going straight through to her voicemail.
up from the Monon Highbridge trail on his way home. Although they hadn't organized the specific meeting time, the trail didn't take long to navigate, and it was presumed the girls would be finished by the time he arrived. As he approached, Derek sent his daughter a text message to let her know he was on his way. At 3.14pm, Derek pulled up at the trailhead parking lot to find that neither of the girls were there. He sent Liberty several follow-up text messages, but received no response, and his calls went unanswered, going straight through to her voicemail.|||在回家的路上经过莫on高桥步道。尽管他们没有安排具体的见面时间，但走完这条小路花不了多长时间，人们推测他到达时女孩们应该已经走完了。当他接近时，德里克给女儿发了一条短信，让她知道自己在路上。下午3点14分，德里克把车停在步道起点的停车场，发现两个女孩都不在那里。他给利伯蒂发了多条后续短信，但没有收到任何回复，他的电话也无人接听，直接转入了她的语音信箱。
Derek set off in search of the girls, presuming he would intercept them along the trail. Having failed to cross paths with the girls by 3.30pm, Derek considered the possibility that the girls had just wandered too far or lost track of them. He contacted his mother to explain the situation, and word quickly spread that the girls were missing. As further attempts to establish contact with the teens were met with silence, concerns began to shift to more serious scenarios, including that the girls had fallen from the bridge or otherwise sustained a severe injury. A search party was quickly established, with the group on the lookout for Abigail,
Derek set off in search of the girls, presuming he would intercept them along the trail. Having failed to cross paths with the girls by 3.30pm, Derek considered the possibility that the girls had just wandered too far or lost track of them. He contacted his mother to explain the situation, and word quickly spread that the girls were missing. As further attempts to establish contact with the teens were met with silence, concerns began to shift to more serious scenarios, including that the girls had fallen from the bridge or otherwise sustained a severe injury. A search party was quickly established, with the group on the lookout for Abigail,|||德里克出发寻找女孩们，猜测他会在沿途拦截她们。到下午3点30分仍未与女孩们擦肩而过，德里克考虑了女孩们可能只是走得太远或迷路的可能。他联系了母亲解释情况，女孩们失踪的消息迅速传开。随着与青少年建立联系的进一步尝试均石沉大海，人们的担忧开始转向更严重的情况，包括女孩们从桥上摔下或受到其他严重伤害。搜救队迅速成立，搜寻小组开始寻找阿比盖尔……
who was 5'4", with long blonde hair and hazel eyes, and Liberty, who was of similar height with shoulder-length blonde hair and blue eyes. She had left home wearing a tie-dyed t-shirt with fringing at the hem, gray sweatpants, and black Nike sneakers. By 5pm, there was still no sign of either of the girls, and as daylight was starting to fade, the families decided it was time to report them as missing. Delphi police reacted immediately, and officers arrived at the trail within minutes, soon joined by members of the Delphi Fire Department, Carroll County Sheriff's Department,
who was 5'4", with long blonde hair and hazel eyes, and Liberty, who was of similar height with shoulder-length blonde hair and blue eyes. She had left home wearing a tie-dyed t-shirt with fringing at the hem, gray sweatpants, and black Nike sneakers. By 5pm, there was still no sign of either of the girls, and as daylight was starting to fade, the families decided it was time to report them as missing. Delphi police reacted immediately, and officers arrived at the trail within minutes, soon joined by members of the Delphi Fire Department, Carroll County Sheriff's Department,|||她身高5英尺4英寸（约1.6米），留着金色长发，长着榛色眼睛；以及利伯蒂，她身高相仿，留着齐肩金发和蓝色眼睛。她离开家时穿着一件下摆有流苏的扎染T恤、灰色运动裤和黑色耐克运动鞋。到下午5点，两个女孩仍然踪迹全无，随着天光开始暗淡，家属们决定是时候报警她们失踪了。德尔斐警方立即做出反应，警官们在几分钟内赶到了步道，不久后德尔斐消防局、卡Carroll县警长办公室的成员也加入了进来……
the Natural Research Department, and the Police Department. Delphi Fire Department, Carroll County Sheriff's Department, the Natural Resources Department, and local volunteers. Hundreds of people armed with flashlights scoured the site, while others marched the local streets, looking for any sign of the missing girls. At 6.30pm, volunteers visited a 40-acre property on Carroll County Road that backed on to Deer Creek, which belonged to long-time Delphi resident, 77-year-old Ronald Logan, who had lived on the property for over 50 years.
the Natural Research Department, and the Police Department. Delphi Fire Department, Carroll County Sheriff's Department, the Natural Resources Department, and local volunteers. Hundreds of people armed with flashlights scoured the site, while others marched the local streets, looking for any sign of the missing girls. At 6.30pm, volunteers visited a 40-acre property on Carroll County Road that backed on to Deer Creek, which belonged to long-time Delphi resident, 77-year-old Ronald Logan, who had lived on the property for over 50 years.|||自然资源部和警察局。德尔斐消防局、卡罗尔县警长办公室、自然资源部和当地志愿者。数百人手持手电筒搜寻现场，其他人则在当地街道上游行，寻找失踪女孩的任何踪迹。晚上6点30分，志愿者们造访了卡罗尔县路上一处背靠鹿溪、面积达40英亩的房产，该房产属于德尔斐的长期居民、77岁的罗纳德·洛根（Ronald Logan），他在该房产上居住已超过50年。
Logan was informed of the incident and granted the search party access to comb his massive property. When night fell, the search was formally postponed as the rugged surroundings were deemed far too dangerous to navigate in the dark, but several members of the girls' families remained too distraught to sleep and continued looking throughout the night. In a statement released to the community, Carroll County Sheriff Tobe Leshamby maintained there was nothing to indicate that the girls were in imminent danger, and stated the police had no reason to suspect foul play. The search resumed at dawn the following morning of Tuesday, February 14.
Logan was informed of the incident and granted the search party access to comb his massive property. When night fell, the search was formally postponed as the rugged surroundings were deemed far too dangerous to navigate in the dark, but several members of the girls' families remained too distraught to sleep and continued looking throughout the night. In a statement released to the community, Carroll County Sheriff Tobe Leshamby maintained there was nothing to indicate that the girls were in imminent danger, and stated the police had no reason to suspect foul play. The search resumed at dawn the following morning of Tuesday, February 14.|||洛根被告知了这一事件，并准许搜查队进入他那巨大的房产进行搜查。夜幕降临后，由于崎岖的环境被认为在黑暗中行走过于危险，搜寻工作被正式推迟，但女孩们的几位家属仍然悲痛欲绝无法入睡，并在整夜继续寻找。在向社区发布的声明中，卡罗尔县警长托比·莱尚比（Tobe Leshamby）坚称没有任何迹象表明女孩们处于迫在眉睫的危险之中，并表示警方没有理由怀疑存在谋杀。搜寻工作于次日2月14日星期二黎明时分恢复。
Members of the local community turned up in droves, joined by concerned citizens from surrounding towns who wanted to lend a hand after seeing the social media posts circulating about the missing teens. The hundreds of volunteers were divided into groups of 10-12, with each equipped with maps and instructed to cover designated areas ranging from 20-25 miles. Volunteers trekked through muddy fields and roadsides, checking barns and adjacent plots of land for any indication the girls may have been there. They looked for clothing, discarded drink bottles, or any other belongings the pair might have dropped. Back at police headquarters, investigators said about scrutinizing CCTV footage pulled
Members of the local community turned up in droves, joined by concerned citizens from surrounding towns who wanted to lend a hand after seeing the social media posts circulating about the missing teens. The hundreds of volunteers were divided into groups of 10-12, with each equipped with maps and instructed to cover designated areas ranging from 20-25 miles. Volunteers trekked through muddy fields and roadsides, checking barns and adjacent plots of land for any indication the girls may have been there. They looked for clothing, discarded drink bottles, or any other belongings the pair might have dropped. Back at police headquarters, investigators said about scrutinizing CCTV footage pulled|||当地社区的成员蜂拥而至，来自周边城镇的关切市民也加入进来，他们在看到关于失踪青少年的社交媒体帖子后前来伸出援手。数百名志愿者被分为10-12人的小组，每组配备地图，并被指示覆盖20-25英里不等的指定区域。志愿者们跋涉在泥泞的田野和路边，检查谷仓和邻近的地块，寻找女孩们可能去过那里的任何迹象。他们寻找衣服、丢弃的饮料瓶或这对组合可能掉落的任何其他物品。回到警察总部，调查人员开始仔细审查提取的监控录像……
from local businesses and security cameras positioned near the trails, but failed to discover anything of note. At 2pm, a press conference was called at Delphi's City Hall, with law enforcement present from Delphi's local police department, the Carroll County Sheriff's Department, and the Indiana State Police. Officers revealed that at 12.15pm, search crews had found two bodies at the bottom of a hill in a wooded area of a privately owned property 50 feet north of the banks of Deer Creek. The discovery was made one mile upstream from the Monon High Bridge, an area characterized by rough sloped terrain only accessible on foot. They refused to disclose the exact location,
from local businesses and security cameras positioned near the trails, but failed to discover anything of note. At 2pm, a press conference was called at Delphi's City Hall, with law enforcement present from Delphi's local police department, the Carroll County Sheriff's Department, and the Indiana State Police. Officers revealed that at 12.15pm, search crews had found two bodies at the bottom of a hill in a wooded area of a privately owned property 50 feet north of the banks of Deer Creek. The discovery was made one mile upstream from the Monon High Bridge, an area characterized by rough sloped terrain only accessible on foot. They refused to disclose the exact location,|||来自当地企业和放置在步道附近的安防摄像头的录像，但未能发现任何值得注意的东西。下午2点，德尔斐市政厅召开了一场新闻发布会，德尔斐当地警察局、卡罗尔县警长办公室和印第安纳州警察局的执法人员出席了会议。警官们透露，下午12点15分，搜救人员在鹿溪岸边以北50英尺处一处私人所有的房产树林里的山坡底部发现了两具尸体。这一发现是在莫on高桥上游一英里处发现的，该地区的地形特点是只能步行进入的崎岖斜坡地形。他们拒绝透露具体地点、……
the identities of the deceased, or the cause of their death, with Delphi Police Chief Steve Mullen simply stating, based on the way the bodies were found, foul play is suspected. As to whether or not local residents should be concerned for their safety, Chief Mullen said he would leave it to the community to decide how they should react, but advised them to avoid the Monon High Bridge trail, and to maintain awareness of their surroundings. The following day, Wednesday, February 15, police held a second press conference to confirm that the two bodies found were indeed those of Abigail Williams and Liberty German. The pair had been located at the rear of the Carroll County Road property belonging to Ronald Logan,
the identities of the deceased, or the cause of their death, with Delphi Police Chief Steve Mullen simply stating, based on the way the bodies were found, foul play is suspected. As to whether or not local residents should be concerned for their safety, Chief Mullen said he would leave it to the community to decide how they should react, but advised them to avoid the Monon High Bridge trail, and to maintain awareness of their surroundings. The following day, Wednesday, February 15, police held a second press conference to confirm that the two bodies found were indeed those of Abigail Williams and Liberty German. The pair had been located at the rear of the Carroll County Road property belonging to Ronald Logan,|||死者的身份或死因，德尔斐警察局长史蒂夫·穆伦（Steve Mullen）只是简单地表示，根据发现尸体的方式，怀疑涉及他杀。至于当地居民是否应该担心自身安全，穆伦局长表示，他将由社区决定如何反应，但建议他们避开莫on高桥步道，并保持对周围环境的警惕。第二天，即2月15日星期三，警方召开了第二场新闻发布会，确认发现的两具尸体确实是阿比盖尔·威廉姆斯和利伯蒂·日耳曼。这两人被发现在属于罗纳德·洛根的卡罗尔县路房产的后方，……
roughly half a mile east of the Delphi cemetery. Police announced they were treating the case as a double homicide, the first in Delphi in more than 20 years, though they declined to comment on the cause of death, crime scene findings, or whether the murders had been a random or targeted attack. Indiana State Police Sergeant Kim Riley stated, there is somebody out there who did this, and we're going to track them down. Police released two small pixelated images they believed could aid their investigation. The pictures depicted a lone Caucasian male wearing a brown cap, a scarf, a hooded sweatshirt, and a zipped up navy blue windbreaker. He was walking along with his head tilted downwards,
roughly half a mile east of the Delphi cemetery. Police announced they were treating the case as a double homicide, the first in Delphi in more than 20 years, though they declined to comment on the cause of death, crime scene findings, or whether the murders had been a random or targeted attack. Indiana State Police Sergeant Kim Riley stated, there is somebody out there who did this, and we're going to track them down. Police released two small pixelated images they believed could aid their investigation. The pictures depicted a lone Caucasian male wearing a brown cap, a scarf, a hooded sweatshirt, and a zipped up navy blue windbreaker. He was walking along with his head tilted downwards,|||大约在德尔斐公墓以东半英里处。警方宣布，他们将此案视为一桩双重凶杀案，这是德尔斐20多年来首起此类案件，不过他们拒绝就死因、犯罪现场调查结果或谋杀是随机袭击还是有针对性的袭击发表评论。印第安纳州警察中士金·莱利（Kim Riley）表示：“外面有人做了这件事，我们将追踪他们。”警方发布了两张像素化的清晰度不高的小照片，他们认为这有助于调查。照片描绘了一名单独的白人男性，头戴棕色帽子，围着围巾，穿着连帽衫和拉链深蓝色风衣。他一边走着，头一边向下倾斜，……
and his left hand tucked into the front pocket of his baggy blue jeans. The image had been captured on the Monon High Bridge at the time that Abigail and Liberty were hiking in the area, but the police refused to comment on who took the photo. They didn't name the man in the photo as a suspect, but stated they wished to speak with him regarding the investigation. Efforts to identify the unknown man were hindered by the fact the blurred photo was taken from a considerable distance, and his face was obstructed by his posture and attire. The image was widely circulated on social media, resulting in hundreds of tips to police, but none led to his identification, nor did the man himself contact authorities.
and his left hand tucked into the front pocket of his baggy blue jeans. The image had been captured on the Monon High Bridge at the time that Abigail and Liberty were hiking in the area, but the police refused to comment on who took the photo. They didn't name the man in the photo as a suspect, but stated they wished to speak with him regarding the investigation. Efforts to identify the unknown man were hindered by the fact the blurred photo was taken from a considerable distance, and his face was obstructed by his posture and attire. The image was widely circulated on social media, resulting in hundreds of tips to police, but none led to his identification, nor did the man himself contact authorities.|||左手插在宽松蓝色牛仔裤的前口袋里。这张照片是在阿比盖尔和利伯蒂在该地区徒步旅行时在莫on高桥上拍摄的，但警方拒绝就谁拍摄了这张照片发表评论。他们没有将照片中的男子点名为嫌疑人，但表示希望就调查事宜与他交谈。由于模糊的照片是在相当远的距离拍摄的，且他的面部被姿势和衣着遮挡，识别这名未知男子的努力受到了阻碍。该图像在社交媒体上广泛流传，导致警方收到了数百条线索，但没有一条能确认他的身份，该男子本人也没有联系当局.
That evening, 700 people gathered at the Delphi United Methodist Church to attend a prayer vigil held for Abigail, Liberty, and their grieving families. A low crime rate had once cemented the small town's communal sense of trust, but now suspicion, anxiety, and panic were pervading Delphi. Local high school student Katie told a newspaper, I just look at everyone I know now and wonder, what if it was them? There is only around 3000 people here, so there's an extremely good chance it is someone a lot of people know who did it. The Monon High Bridge trail had long been considered a safe place to track, but one of its developers, Dan McCain, believed this sense of safety would change as a result of
That evening, 700 people gathered at the Delphi United Methodist Church to attend a prayer vigil held for Abigail, Liberty, and their grieving families. A low crime rate had once cemented the small town's communal sense of trust, but now suspicion, anxiety, and panic were pervading Delphi. Local high school student Katie told a newspaper, I just look at everyone I know now and wonder, what if it was them? There is only around 3000 people here, so there's an extremely good chance it is someone a lot of people know who did it. The Monon High Bridge trail had long been considered a safe place to track, but one of its developers, Dan McCain, believed this sense of safety would change as a result of|||当晚，700人聚集在德尔斐联合卫理公会教堂，参加为阿比盖尔、利伯蒂及其悲痛的家属举行的烛光祈祷会。低犯罪率曾巩固了这个小镇的社区信任感，但现在怀疑、焦虑和恐慌正笼罩着德尔斐.当地高中生凯蒂（Katie）告诉一家报纸：“我现在看着认识的每个人都会想，万一凶手是他们呢？这里只有大约3000人，所以凶手极有可能是很多认识的人。”莫on高桥步道长期以来一直被认为是安全的徒步地点，但其开发者之一丹·麦凯恩（Dan McCain）认为，这种安全感将因……
the murders, stating, I know people will be afraid now, I just know that, and for that, I'm devastated too. Classes had resumed at Delphi Community Middle School, but all after-school activities were cancelled for the remainder of the week. A therapy dog and counsellors were brought in to assist students struggling to cope with the loss of their classmates, as school administrators implemented tougher restrictions to limit who was permitted to enter the campus and have contact with students. The following night of Thursday, February 16, police executed a search warrant for a residential property on West Bicycle Bridge Road, a long rural road on the western outskirts of Delphi. The male homeowner was interviewed, his premises searched, and some items seized,
the murders, stating, I know people will be afraid now, I just know that, and for that, I'm devastated too. Classes had resumed at Delphi Community Middle School, but all after-school activities were cancelled for the remainder of the week. A therapy dog and counsellors were brought in to assist students struggling to cope with the loss of their classmates, as school administrators implemented tougher restrictions to limit who was permitted to enter the campus and have contact with students. The following night of Thursday, February 16, police executed a search warrant for a residential property on West Bicycle Bridge Road, a long rural road on the western outskirts of Delphi. The male homeowner was interviewed, his premises searched, and some items seized,|||这起谋杀案而改变，他说：“我知道人们现在会害怕，我就是知道这一点，为此我也感到崩溃。”德尔斐社区中学的课程已经恢复，但本周剩下的所有课外活动都被取消了。学校引入了治疗犬和辅导员来协助那些难以应对失去同学之痛的学生，同时学校管理者实施了更严格的限制，以限制谁被允许进入校园并与学生接触。2月16日星期四的次日晚上，警方对位于德尔斐西郊的一条漫长乡村公路——西自行车桥路（West Bicycle Bridge Road）的一处住宅房产执行了搜查令。男房主接受了讯问，其住所遭到搜查，并扣押了一些物品，……
but police left without placing anyone under arrest. Nevertheless, the investigative spotlight caught the attention of the local community, compelling some just as seeking townsfolk to flock to the address, while others made threats against the man online. In order to quell the harassment, police publicly announced that the man had been cleared, before warning the public to leave the investigation to law enforcement professionals. On Saturday, February 18, a fundraiser benefit ride held in support of Abigail and Deliberty's families saw an anticipated crowd of several hundred people grow to more than 3,000. Cars and motorcycles packed downtown Delphi, with traffic pouring in from nearby towns and counties.
but police left without placing anyone under arrest. Nevertheless, the investigative spotlight caught the attention of the local community, compelling some just as seeking townsfolk to flock to the address, while others made threats against the man online. In order to quell the harassment, police publicly announced that the man had been cleared, before warning the public to leave the investigation to law enforcement professionals. On Saturday, February 18, a fundraiser benefit ride held in support of Abigail and Deliberty's families saw an anticipated crowd of several hundred people grow to more than 3,000. Cars and motorcycles packed downtown Delphi, with traffic pouring in from nearby towns and counties.|||但警方离开时没有逮捕任何人。尽管如此，调查的聚光灯还是引起了当地社区的注意，迫使一些寻找正义的镇民蜂拥至该地址，而另一些人则在网上对该男子发出威胁。为了平息骚扰，警方公开宣布该男子已被洗清嫌疑，并警告公众将调查留给执法专业人员。2月18日星期六，为支持阿比盖尔和利伯蒂家属而举办的慈善骑行筹款活动吸引了原本预计几百人的群众，人数激增至3000多人。汽车和摩托车挤满了德尔斐市中心，来自附近城镇和县的交通源源不断地涌入。
Raffle draws and bake sales also took place, while bracelets were sold bearing Abigail and Deliberty's names along with the message hashtag pray for Delphi. At 4pm, thousands of mourners gathered at the Delphi community high school gymnasium to pay their respects during a memorial service for the girls. Video footage of Abigail and Deliberty played on a screen inside, and tables were covered in memorabilia paying homage to their short yet impactful lives. At 8pm, the crowds grouped together outside to release dozens of golden lanterns into Delphi's night sky. The next day of Sunday, February 19, the Delphi United Methodist Church clergy
Raffle draws and bake sales also took place, while bracelets were sold bearing Abigail and Deliberty's names along with the message hashtag pray for Delphi. At 4pm, thousands of mourners gathered at the Delphi community high school gymnasium to pay their respects during a memorial service for the girls. Video footage of Abigail and Deliberty played on a screen inside, and tables were covered in memorabilia paying homage to their short yet impactful lives. At 8pm, the crowds grouped together outside to release dozens of golden lanterns into Delphi's night sky. The next day of Sunday, February 19, the Delphi United Methodist Church clergy|||现场还举行了抽奖和烘焙义卖，同时出售印有阿比盖尔和利伯蒂名字以及“为德尔斐祈祷”话题标签的手链。下午4点，数千名哀悼者聚集在德尔斐社区高中体育馆，在女孩们的追悼会上表达敬意。阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的视频片段在内部屏幕上播放，桌子上摆满了纪念品，向她们短暂却影响深远的人生致敬。晚上8点，人群聚集在外面，将数十盏金色天灯放入德尔斐的夜空中。第二天，即2月19日星期日，德尔斐联合卫理公会教堂的神职人员……
invited the town's residents to come in to write their anxieties down on colorful post-it notes, and stick them to two large crosses on display inside. Some notes featured a single word, such as sympathy, fear or disbelief, while others contained longer messages expressing the rider's anger and grief. That same morning, separate funerals were held for Abigail, Williams and Deliberty German, with traffic in downtown Delphi coming to a standstill as the processions rolled through, 45 minutes apart. On the day of the funerals, police held another press conference in which they officially named the male who was photographed on Monon High Bridge as a suspect in Abigail and Deliberty's murders. They refused to comment on the origin of the
invited the town's residents to come in to write their anxieties down on colorful post-it notes, and stick them to two large crosses on display inside. Some notes featured a single word, such as sympathy, fear or disbelief, other contained longer messages expressing the rider's anger and grief. That same morning, separate funerals were held for Abigail, Williams and Deliberty German, with traffic in downtown Delphi coming to a standstill as the processions rolled through, 45 minutes apart. On the day of the funerals, police held another press conference in which they officially named the male who was photographed on Monon High Bridge as a suspect in Abigail and Deliberty's murders. They refused to comment on the origin of the|||邀请镇上的居民前来，将他们的焦虑写在五颜六色的便利贴上，并将其贴在内部展示的两个大十字架上。一些便签只有一个词，例如同情、恐惧或难以置信，而另一些则包含更长的信息，表达了书写者的愤怒和悲伤。同日上午，阿比盖尔·威廉姆斯和利伯蒂·日耳曼分别举行了葬礼，由于送葬队伍相隔45分钟缓缓驶过，德尔斐市中心的交通陷入瘫痪。在葬礼当天，警方举行了另一场新闻发布会，正式将莫on高桥上被拍到的男子列为阿比盖尔和利伯蒂谋杀案的嫌疑人。他们拒绝就该照片的来源发表评论，……
picture, but explained that its poor quality was due to it having been cropped from a larger image. This update prompted a flood of tips, but none that immediately identified the suspect, leading police to believe he may have been a loner or a drifter who left Delphi following the crime. Some witnesses reported seeing a hitchhiker passing through Delphi on the day of the murders, via the four-laneed Hoosier Heartland Highway, which connects the cities of Lafayette and Fort Wayne, and passes directly by the Monon High Bridge Trail. Following these reports, police appealed for information about any strangers seen walking out of town the day the girls went missing. Up until this point, law enforcement had taken
picture, but explained that its poor quality was due to it having been cropped from a larger image. This update prompted a flood of tips, but none that immediately identified the suspect, leading police to believe he may have been a loner or a drifter who left Delphi following the crime. Some witnesses reported seeing a hitchhiker passing through Delphi on the day of the murders, via the four-laneed Hoosier Heartland Highway, which connects the cities of Lafayette and Fort Wayne, and passes directly by the Monon High Bridge Trail. Following these reports, police appealed for information about any strangers seen walking out of town the day the girls went missing. Up until this point, law enforcement had taken|||但解释说其质量差是因为它是从一幅更大的图像中裁剪出来的。这一更新引发了大量线索，但没有一条能立即辨认出嫌疑人，这让警方认为他可能是一个在犯罪后离开德尔斐的独行侠或流浪汉。一些目击者报告称，在谋杀案当天，看到一名搭便车的人穿过德尔斐，途径连接拉斐特和韦恩堡两市、直接从莫on高桥步道旁经过的四车道印第安纳心脏地带高速公路（Hoosier Heartland Highway）。根据这些报告，警方呼吁提供有关在女孩失踪当天看到有陌生人步行出城的任何信息。在此之前，执法部门采取了……
a cautious approach in their efforts to publicise the case and find the killer, endeavouring to share crucial information without compromising the integrity of their investigation. The public were kept in the dark about how Abigail and Deliberty had been killed, and what evidence, if any, had been obtained at the crime scene. Although the absence of information led to public speculation and rumours, withholding these details was a strategic move by police to ensure that only the killer knew the specifics of the crime. That way, if a confession was ever obtained, they could easily determine its legitimacy. Wednesday, February 22 marked nine days since Abigail and Deliberty's bodies were found.
a cautious approach in their efforts to publicise the case and find the killer, endeavouring to share crucial information without compromising the integrity of their investigation. The public were kept in the dark about how Abigail and Deliberty had been killed, and what evidence, if any, had been obtained at the crime scene. Although the absence of information led to public speculation and rumours, withholding these details was a strategic move by police to ensure that only the killer knew the specifics of the crime. That way, if a confession was ever obtained, they could easily determine its legitimacy. Wednesday, February 22 marked nine days since Abigail and Deliberty's bodies were found.|||谨慎的方法来宣传此案并寻找凶手，努力在不损害调查完整性的前提下分享关键信息。公众对阿比盖尔和利伯蒂是如何被杀害的，以及在犯罪现场获得了什么证据（如果有的话）一无所知。尽管信息的匮乏导致了公众的猜测和谣言，但隐瞒这些细节是警方的一项战略举措，旨在确保只有凶手才知道犯罪的具体细节。这样，如果以后获得供词，他们就能轻松确定其合法性。2月22日星期三，距离发现阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的尸体已经过去九天了。
Crowds packed into the Delphi United Methodist Church in anticipation of a police press conference which promised to unveil additional details of the investigation. Indiana State Police Sergeant Tony Slocum began the conference by thanking the community and media for their patience and support, despite having been kept in the dark, stating, this investigation is too important to make any mistakes and give out the wrong information. The large group of investigators flanking Sergeant Slocum provided an indication of the massive amount of local, county, state, and federal resources dedicated to solving the case. Police provided two key revelations. The first was that the blurred images released of the suspect
Crowds packed into the Delphi United Methodist Church in anticipation of a police press conference which promised to unveil additional details of the investigation. Indiana State Police Sergeant Tony Slocum began the conference by thanking the community and media for their patience and support, despite having been kept in the dark, stating, this investigation is too important to make any mistakes and give out the wrong information. The large group of investigators flanking Sergeant Slocum provided an indication of the massive amount of local, county, state, and federal resources dedicated to solving the case. Police provided two key revelations. The first was that the blurred images released of the suspect|||人群挤满了德尔斐联合卫理公会教堂，期待着一场承诺揭示调查更多细节的警方新闻发布会。印第安纳州警察中士托尼·斯洛库姆（Tony Slocum）在会议开始时感谢社区和媒体在蒙在鼓里的情况下展现出的耐心与支持，并表示：“这项调查太重要了，容不得半点错误，也绝不能提供错误的信息。”站在斯洛库姆中士身旁庞大的调查人员队伍表明，为了破案投入了海量的本地、县、州和联邦资源。警方提供了两个关键披露。第一个是发布的 suspect 模糊图像……
crossing Monon High Bridge had been obtained from Liberty German's smartphone. It was not established whether the police had recovered the device itself or if they had accessed its contents via the cloud. As she and Abigail crossed the bridge on February 13, Liberty had turned on her phone's video camera to film the man as he was following them, although police did not reveal the full extent of the footage or how long it went for. The second revelation was that Liberty had also managed to record audio of the suspect's voice. Police played a segment of the audio for those present, in which a man with a gruff, authoritative tone could be heard saying, down the hill. According to investigators, additional footage had been obtained from Liberty's
crossing Monon High Bridge had been obtained from Liberty German's smartphone. It was not established whether the police had recovered the device itself or if they had accessed its contents via the cloud. As she and Abigail crossed the bridge on February 13, Liberty had turned on her phone's video camera to film the man as he was following them, although police did not reveal the full extent of the footage or how long it went for. The second revelation was that Liberty had also managed to record audio of the suspect's voice. Police played a segment of the audio for those present, in which a man with a gruff, authoritative tone could be heard saying, down the hill. According to investigators, additional footage had been obtained from Liberty's|||穿过莫on高桥的照片是从利伯蒂·日耳曼的智能手机中获取的。目前尚不确定警方是找回了设备本身，还是通过云端访问了其内容。2月13日她和阿比盖尔过桥时，利伯蒂打开了手机的摄像机，拍摄了那名尾随他们的男子，尽管警方并未透露录像的全部内容或持续时间。第二个披露是，利伯蒂还设法录下了嫌疑人的声音。警方为在场人员播放了一段音频，其中可以听到一个粗鲁、权威的男声在说：“下山（down the hill）。”据调查人员称，从利伯蒂的……
mobile phone, along with other undisclosed evidence, but would remain classified. Sergeant Tony Slocum praised Liberty for her quick thinking and courage. Quote, Liberty German is a hero, there's no doubt, to have enough presence of mind to activate that video system on her cell phone to record what we believe is criminal behavior that's about to occur. An extended version of the audio was played exclusively to Liberty and Abigail's families. According to state police, the longer recording included the girls talking about, quote, stuff girls talk about, but the pair also mentioned the man walking behind them. What transpired between this interaction and the publicly released audio segment of the suspect
mobile phone, along with other undisclosed evidence, but would remain classified. Sergeant Tony Slocum praised Liberty for her quick thinking and courage. Quote, Liberty German is a hero, there's no doubt, to have enough presence of mind to activate that video system on her cell phone to record what we believe is criminal behavior that's about to occur. An extended version of the audio was played exclusively to Liberty and Abigail's families. According to state police, the longer recording included the girls talking about, quote, stuff girls talk about, but the pair also mentioned the man walking behind them. What transpired between this interaction and the publicly released audio segment of the suspect|||手机中获取了更多录像，连同其他未公开的证据，但这些将继续保密。托尼·斯洛库姆中士赞扬了利伯蒂的机智和勇气。引用原话：“利伯蒂·日耳曼毫无疑问是个英雄，她有足够的清醒头脑启动手机上的视频系统，记录下我们认为是即将发生的犯罪行为。”音频的加长版仅向利伯蒂和阿比盖尔的家属播放。据州警察称，较长的录音包括女孩们谈论“女孩们谈论的事情”，但两人也提到了走在她们身后的那个男人。这次互动与公开的嫌疑人音频片段之间发生了什么……
making the demand down the hill remained undisclosed. The community were urged to report anyone they knew who had abruptly missed work or canceled plans on February 13, or had changed their appearance, behavior, travel plans, sleep patterns, or substance use in the days following the murders. In addition to studying the suspect's clothing, investigators encouraged the public to consider his posture and mannerisms, such as the way his hand was placed in his pants pocket, as these minor habits may appear familiar to those who knew him. Police reiterated that no detail was too small and implored citizens to name all possible persons
making the demand down the hill remained undisclosed. The community were urged to report anyone they knew who had abruptly missed work or canceled plans on February 13, or had changed their appearance, behavior, travel plans, sleep patterns, or substance use in the days following the murders. In addition to studying the suspect's clothing, investigators encouraged the public to consider his posture and mannerisms, such as the way his hand was placed in his pants pocket, as these minor habits may appear familiar to those who knew him. Police reiterated that no detail was too small and implored citizens to name all possible persons|||提出“下山”的要求，目前仍未公开。社区被敦促举报任何他们认识的人，这些人在2月13日突然旷工或取消了计划，或者在谋杀案发生后的几天里改变了外表、行为、旅行计划、睡眠模式或药物使用。除了研究嫌疑人的衣着外，调查人员还鼓励公众考虑他的姿势和举止，比如他把手放在裤袋里的方式，因为这些微小的习惯在认识他的人看来可能会很熟悉。警方重申，没有哪个细节是微不足道的，并恳求市民说出所有可能的……
of interest, even if they believed that individual was incapable of committing such crimes. A $41,000 reward was launched for information leading to an arrest, with FBI Special Agent Greg Messer firmly stating he was confident that the case will be solved. Indiana State Police Superintendent Douglas Carter said, We must keep our resolve for Libby and Abbey, for this community, and frankly, to ensure that good trumps evil. He ended the conference with a message to the perpetrator, warning, if you are watching, we'll find you.
of interest, even if they believed that individual was incapable of committing such crimes. A $41,000 reward was launched for information leading to an arrest, with FBI Special Agent Greg Messer firmly stating he was confident that the case will be solved. Indiana State Police Superintendent Douglas Carter said, We must keep our resolve for Libby and Abbey, for this community, and frankly, to ensure that good trumps evil. He ended the conference with a message to the perpetrator, warning, if you are watching, we'll find you.|||关注对象，即使他们认为该个人没有能力犯下此类罪行。悬赏41,000美元以征集能够促成逮捕的信息，联邦调查局（FBI）特工格雷格·梅瑟（Greg Messer）坚定地表示，他坚信此案将会告破。印第安纳州警察总监道格拉斯·卡特（Douglas Carter）说：“为了莉比和艾比，为了这个社区，坦率地说，为了确保正义战胜邪恶，我们必须保持坚定不移的决心。”他在会议结束时向凶手传达了一条信息，警告道：“如果你在看，我们会找到你的。”
By March, detectives from two dozen agencies were diligently making their way through nearly 8,000 tips provided via the case's phone hotline and e-mail account. In an effort to better support the large number of officers actively working on the case, the investigation headquarters were relocated from the Delphi Municipal Building to the REMC Building in downtown Carroll County. Messages of support were hung up inside to motivate detectives, with one reading, when you feel like quitting, think about why you started. A framed photograph of Abigail and Liberty featured the statement,
By March, detectives from two dozen agencies were diligently making their way through nearly 8,000 tips provided via the case's phone hotline and e-mail account. In an effort to better support the large number of officers actively working on the case, the investigation headquarters were relocated from the Delphi Municipal Building to the REMC Building in downtown Carroll County. Messages of support were hung up inside to motivate detectives, with one reading, when you feel like quitting, think about why you started. A framed photograph of Abigail and Liberty featured the statement,|||到了3月，来自二十几个机构的侦探们正在认真梳理通过案件热线电话和电子邮箱提供的近8,000条线索。为了更好地支持大量积极侦办此案的警官，调查总部从德尔斐市政大楼搬迁至卡罗尔县市中心的REMC大楼。内部悬挂着支持的信息以激励侦探们，其中一条写着：“当你想要放弃时，想想你为什么开始。”一张阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的带框照片上写着：
some people come into our lives and quickly go, some stay for a while, leave footprints on our hearts, and we are never, ever the same. A nationwide campaign saw 6,000 electronic billboards crop up across 48 states, featuring photographs of Abigail and Liberty alongside the image of their suspected killer, with a call to action from the FBI. Meanwhile, the disturbing audio clip of the suspect's voice was broadcast extensively over national radio stations. The notoriety of the unsolved case, coupled with its many unanswered questions, provoked rampant rumours and speculation among citizen sleuths,
some people come into our lives and quickly go, some stay for a while, leave footprints on our hearts, and we are never, ever the same. A nationwide campaign saw 6,000 electronic billboards crop up across 48 states, featuring photographs of Abigail and Liberty alongside the image of their suspected killer, with a call to action from the FBI. Meanwhile, the disturbing audio clip of the suspect's voice was broadcast extensively over national radio stations. The notoriety of the unsolved case, coupled with its many unanswered questions, provoked rampant rumours and speculation among citizen sleuths,|||“有些人走进我们的生活又匆匆离去，有些人停留了一会儿，在我们的心中留下足迹，而我们再也、再也回不到从前。”一场全国性的运动在48个州涌现了6,000块电子广告牌，上面印有阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的照片以及她们涉嫌凶手的画像，并附有FBI的行动呼吁。与此同时，嫌疑人声音令人不安的音频剪辑在全国广播电台广泛播出。这起未破案件的恶名，加上许多未解之谜，引发了民间侦探们的疯狂传言和猜测……
who used social media to wrongfully accuse men across the country of being the unknown suspect. This behaviour prompted police to issue a warning that individuals who made such accusations were participating in defamation and opening themselves up to a potential lawsuit. Others spread online fear by theorizing that the murders were the work of a serial killer, and attempted to establish connections to other unsolved crimes or recent deaths in Indiana. Police asserted the murders did not share any link to other known homicides, and requested members of the public to avoid buying into any news that wasn't official information provided by law enforcement agencies. The Delphi community remained vigilant,
who used social media to wrongfully accuse men across the country of being the unknown suspect. This behaviour prompted police to issue a warning that individuals who made such accusations were participating in defamation and opening themselves up to a potential lawsuit. Others spread online fear by theorizing that the murders were the work of a serial killer, and attempted to establish connections to other unsolved crimes or recent deaths in Indiana. Police asserted the murders did not share any link to other known homicides, and requested members of the public to avoid buying into any news that wasn't official information provided by law enforcement agencies. The Delphi community remained vigilant,|||他们利用社交媒体无端指责全国各地的男性为未知的嫌疑人。这种行为促使警方发出警告，称进行此类指控的个人正在参与诽谤，并将自己置于潜在诉讼的风险之中。其他人则通过推测谋杀案是连环杀手所为来散布网络恐惧，并试图将其与印第安纳州的其他未破案件或近期死亡事件联系起来。警方断言，这些谋杀案与任何其他已知凶杀案都没有联系，并要求公众不要相信任何非执法机构提供的官方信息的传闻。德尔斐社区依然保持警惕，……
with many believing the suspect lived amongst them. Local women and children signed up for self-defense classes to better protect themselves, while a task force was established to field recommendations from the public as to how safety could be improved on Delphi's historic trail system. Abigail and Deliberty's families were inundated with ongoing support, with businesses and organizations holding fundraisers to provide them with financial assistance, and to increase the amount of the reward pool. A sign placed on the door of one participating restaurant, Delphi Peter King, read,
with many believing the suspect lived amongst them. Local women and children signed up for self-defense classes to better protect themselves, while a task force was established to field recommendations from the public as to how safety could be improved on Delphi's historic trail system. Abigail and Deliberty's families were inundated with ongoing support, with businesses and organizations holding fundraisers to provide them with financial assistance, and to increase the amount of the reward pool. A sign placed on the door of one participating restaurant, Delphi Peter King, read,|||许多人相信嫌疑人就住在他们中间。当地妇女和儿童报名参加了自卫课程以更好地保护自己，同时成立了一个工作组来收集公众关于如何改善德尔斐历史步道系统安全性的建议。阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的家属被源源不断的支持所淹没，企业和组织举行了募捐活动，为他们提供经济援助，并增加悬赏金额。贴在一家参与活动的餐馆德尔斐彼得金（Delphi Peter King）门上的招牌上写着：
In our community, when bad happens, we band together. 24 days after his granddaughter's murder, Mike Paddy appeared at the Carroll County Courthouse in Delphi to speak publicly about the case for the first time. Supported by his wife, Mike delivered a statement on behalf of Liberty and Abigail's families, which read, This horrible crime has torn a hole in our families that will never heal. It's the small things that seem to hurt the most. It's just natural to holler for them to come to dinner or in the morning to get up and get ready for school. Then expect them to come through the door after school. The silence when we don't hear their voice.
In our community, when bad happens, we band together. 24 days after his granddaughter's murder, Mike Paddy appeared at the Carroll County Courthouse in Delphi to speak publicly about the case for the first time. Supported by his wife, Mike delivered a statement on behalf of Liberty and Abigail's families, which read, This horrible crime has torn a hole in our families that will never heal. It's the small things that seem to hurt the most. It's just natural to holler for them to come to dinner or in the morning to get up and get ready for school. Then expect them to come through the door after school. The silence when we don't hear their voice.|||“在我们的社区里，当坏事发生时，我们团结在一起。”孙女被谋杀24天后，迈克·帕迪出现在德尔斐的卡罗尔县法院，首次就此案公开表态。在妻子的支持下，迈克代表利伯蒂和阿比盖尔的家属发表了一份声明，其中写道：“这起可怕的罪行在我们的家庭中撕开了一个永远无法愈合的伤口。似乎是那些小事伤得最深。大喊让他们来吃晚房，或者早上起床准备上学，这是再自然不过的事情了。然后期待他们放学后走进家门。当我们听不到他们的声音时，那份沉默令人窒息。”
Mike explained that there was a running joke within their household that whenever Liberty was asked to do something, her response would be, In a minute, he implored the public to follow his granddaughter's sentiment in catching her killer, stating, I believe if she were able to speak, she would ask people to please give her the one minute she always asked for, picture of the suspect and listen to the audio clip. Mike candidly defined the unshakable bond between Abigail and Liberty, quote, Both the girls are heroes. They stuck together. I don't know exactly what happened out there that day, but I imagine there was probably an opportunity for one or both to separate and try to make a break in different ways.
Mike explained that there was a running joke within their household that whenever Liberty was asked to do something, her response would be, In a minute, he implored the public to follow his granddaughter's sentiment in catching her killer, stating, I believe if she were able to speak, she would ask people to please give her the one minute she always asked for, picture of the suspect and listen to the audio clip. Mike candidly defined the unshakable bond between Abigail and Liberty, quote, Both the girls are heroes. They stuck together. I don't know exactly what happened out there that day, but I imagine there was probably an opportunity for one or both to separate and try to make a break in different ways.|||迈克解释说，他们家里有一个流传的笑话，每当要求利伯蒂做某事时，她的回答总是：“等一下。”他恳求公众顺应他孙女的心愿来抓住她的凶手，并表示：“我相信如果她能说话，她会请求大家给她她总是要求的那一分钟，看一眼嫌疑人的照片并听听音频片段。”迈克坦诚地定义了阿比盖尔和利伯蒂之间牢不可破的羁绊，原话是：“两个女孩都是英雄。她们团结在一起。我不知道那天外面究竟发生了什么，但我猜可能有一个人或两人分开并试图以不同方式逃脱的机会。”
But those girls loved each other. They were good friends. Neither one of them left each other's side. Following Mike Paddy's emotional plea, tips to police increased 200%, with the total number provided now exceeding 11,000. Despite the number of tips and hundreds of subsequent interviews, the lack of major breakthroughs led to several police departments scaling back their involvement in the investigation, pledging to return when their resources were required. Indiana State Police Sergeant John Pirine explained, This is emotional for all of us. I can tell you that it's not easy, and a lot of people are putting a lot of work into this. We're hoping that the tips there, and we're going to find it.
But those girls loved each other. They were good friends. Neither one of them left each other's side. Following Mike Paddy's emotional plea, tips to police increased 200%, with the total number provided now exceeding 11,000. Despite the number of tips and hundreds of subsequent interviews, the lack of major breakthroughs led to several police departments scaling back their involvement in the investigation, pledging to return when their resources were required. Indiana State Police Sergeant John Pirine explained, This is emotional for all of us. I can tell you that it's not easy, and a lot of people are putting a lot of work into this. We're hoping that the tips there, and we're going to find it.|||“但那些女孩彼此相爱。她们是好朋友。她们谁也没有离开过对方身边。”在迈克·帕迪情绪激昂的恳求之后，提供给警方的线索增加了200%，提供的总数现已超过11,000条。尽管有大量的线索和随后的数百次走访，但由于缺乏重大突破，几个警察局减少了对调查的参与，并承诺在需要其资源时回归。印第安纳州警察中士约翰·皮林（John Pirine）解释说：“这对我们所有人来说都充满情感。我可以告诉你，这并不容易，很多人在这上面付出了大量的工作。我们希望线索在那里，我们会找到凶手的。”
On Saturday, March 18, 15 law enforcement officers executed a search warrant at the Carroll County Road property where Abigail and Liberty's bodies were found a little over a month earlier. At the time the search warrant was carried out, the landowner, 77-year-old Ronald Logan, had been in custody for a week after admitting to violating probation for an unrelated drink driving conviction from 2014. Court mandated conditions for Bade Logan from operating a vehicle, and to when required to provide an alibi for the key date of February 13, 2017. He admitted to driving two miles south to the Carroll County Waste Transfer Station to discard some garbage. He had fully cooperated with search efforts, allowing volunteers and police to inspect his
On Saturday, March 18, 15 law enforcement officers executed a search warrant at the Carroll County Road property where Abigail and Liberty's bodies were found a little over a month earlier. At the time the search warrant was carried out, the landowner, 77-year-old Ronald Logan, had been in custody for a week after admitting to violating probation for an unrelated drink driving conviction from 2014. Court mandated conditions for Bade Logan from operating a vehicle, and to when required to provide an alibi for the key date of February 13, 2017. He admitted to driving two miles south to the Carroll County Waste Transfer Station to discard some garbage. He had fully cooperated with search efforts, allowing volunteers and police to inspect his|||3月18日星期六，15名执法人员在卡罗尔县路的一处房产执行了搜查令，一个多月前，阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的尸体正是在那里被发现的。在执行搜查令时，土地所有者、77岁的罗纳德·Logan已经被拘留了一周，此前他承认因2014年一起无关的酒驾定罪而违反缓刑规定。法院强制规定禁止Logan驾驶车辆，并在被要求时为2017年2月13日这一关键日期提供不在场证明。他承认自己开车向南行驶了两英里，来到卡罗尔县垃圾转运站扔掉了一些垃圾。他曾全力配合搜查工作，允许志愿者和警察检查他的……
property for the missing teens, later describing the grim outcome as like being hit with a bolt of lightning. Two weeks later, he further violated the terms of his probation when he was spotted drinking a beer at a pizza restaurant, and was placed into custody. The inspection of Ronald Logan's home was just one of approximately a dozen search warrants that had been executed so far in the investigation. Detectives ultimately ruled Logan out as a suspect in the murders, but he nevertheless found himself under the harsh scrutiny of internet sleuths, whose efforts to link him to the murders made a profound impact on his reputation. As he awaited trial for his probation violations, Logan had to be transferred to a different county
property for the missing teens, later describing the grim outcome as like being hit with a bolt of lightning. Two weeks later, he further violated the terms of his probation when he was spotted drinking a beer at a pizza restaurant, and was placed into custody. The inspection of Ronald Logan's home was just one of approximately a dozen search warrants that had been executed so far in the investigation. Detectives ultimately ruled Logan out as a suspect in the murders, but he nevertheless found himself under the harsh scrutiny of internet sleuths, whose efforts to link him to the murders made a profound impact on his reputation. As he awaited trial for his probation violations, Logan had to be transferred to a different county|||房产以寻找失踪的青少年，后来他将这一严峻的结果描述为“如同遭到雷击”。两周后，当他在一家比萨餐厅被发现喝啤酒时，他再次违反了缓刑条款，随即被拘留。对罗纳德·Logan住宅的检查只是迄今为止调查中执行的大约十几张搜查令之一。侦探们最终排除Logan为谋杀案嫌疑人，但他仍然发现自己处于网络侦探严厉的审视之下，他们试图将他与谋杀案联系起来的努力对他的声誉产生了深远的影响。在等待违反缓刑规定的审判期间，Logan不得不被转移到另一个县的……
jail he out of fears for his safety. His attorney issued a press release that read, I have known Ronald Logan for several years and have represented him in unrelated legal matters. Stated simply, he had no involvement in this heinous crime. I would like to caution the public to avoid jumping to conclusions before law enforcement has completed the ongoing investigation. Logan was subsequently sentenced to three and a half years in prison for being a habitual traffic offender, but his sentence was later reduced to home detention. Four and a half months after the murders, Abigail's mother Anna Williams posted a video tribute to her daughter online featuring photos of her from infancy through childhood with the caption,
jail he out of fears for his safety. His attorney issued a press release that read, I have known Ronald Logan for several years and have represented him in unrelated legal matters. Stated simply, he had no involvement in this heinous crime. I would like to caution the public to avoid jumping to conclusions before law enforcement has completed the ongoing investigation. Logan was subsequently sentenced to three and a half years in prison for being a habitual traffic offender, but his sentence was later reduced to home detention. Four and a half months after the murders, Abigail's mother Anna Williams posted a video tribute to her daughter online featuring photos of her from infancy through childhood with the caption,|||由于担心自身安全，他被关押在监狱里。他的律师发表了一份新闻稿，其中写道：“我认识罗纳德·Logan已经好几年了，并曾在无关的法律事务中代表过他。简而言之，他没有参与这起滔天罪行。我想提醒公众，在执法部门完成正在进行的调查之前，避免轻率下结论。”Logan随后因惯犯交通违章被判处三年半监禁，但他的刑期后来被减为居家监禁。谋杀案发生四个半月后，阿比盖尔的母亲安娜·威廉姆斯在网上发布了一段向女儿致敬的视频，视频中包含了她从婴儿期到童年的照片，并配文：
Tomorrow, June 23rd, 2017, Abigail Joyce Williams would be turning 14. It is still unbelievable to me that I won't be making a cake and planning her party, not this year, not next year. Please remember her tomorrow and every day. To honor Abigail's birthday, family and friends gathered at the Delphi United Methodist Church to release dozens of colorful lanterns into the sky. After five months of dedicated investigation with no arrests, tips from the public had slowly dwindled to less than 10 per day. On Monday, July 17, in an effort to reignite the case, police released a composite sketch of the suspected killer. The sketch had been created using descriptions provided by witnesses
明天，2017年6月23日，阿比盖尔·乔伊斯·威廉姆斯（Abigail Joyce Williams）就满14岁了。我依然无法相信我不会再为她烤蛋糕、筹划派对，今年不会，明年也不会。请在明天和以后的每一天都记住她。为了纪念阿比盖尔的生日，家人和朋友们聚集在德尔斐联合卫理公会教堂，将数十盏五颜六色的孔明灯放入夜空中。在经过五个月的深入调查却无一人被捕之后，公众提供的线索已经缓慢减少到每天不到10条。7月17日星期一，为了重新推进案件侦破，警方公布了一张嫌疑人的模拟画像。这张画像是根据目击者提供的描述绘制的
who traversed on or near the Monon Hybrid trail on the day of the murders. The sketch had taken months to construct due to the gradual pace at which these witnesses came forward, coupled with the time it took for investigators to verify and collate details between their statements. The male suspect was described as Caucasian, between 5'6 and 5'10 inches tall, weighing 180 to 220 pounds, with reddish brown hair and an unknown eye color. The sketch depicted him as middle-aged with a square face, short hair, small, wide-set eyes and a large nose, with a neatly trimmed goatee. In the drawing, he wore a flat cap, but investigators established this detail might not be accurate, as multiple witnesses were unable to agree on it. They advised the
这些目击者在谋杀案发生当天曾穿行于莫农高地步道（Monon High Bridge Trail）或其附近。由于这些目击者露面的进度缓慢，加上调查人员核对和整理他们之间供词的细节需要时间，这张画像花了几个月的时间才拼凑完成。男嫌疑人被描述为白人，身高在5英尺6英寸到5英尺10英寸之间，体重180到220磅，留着红褐色头发，眼睛颜色不明。画像描绘他为中年人，方脸，短发，眼睛较小且间距较宽，鼻子很大，留着修剪整齐的山羊胡。在画中，他戴着一顶扁帽，但调查人员确定这个细节可能并不准确，因为多位目击者对此无法达成一致。他们建议
sketch should only be viewed as a guide and not as a 100% accurate representation of the suspect. Indiana State Police Sergeant Kim Riley stated, We're going to get to the bottom of this sooner or later. If the composite sketch helps us get there sooner, that's what we're hoping for. Following the release of the sketch, investigators were inundated with information from the public, with 1,000 tips coming through in the first 24 hours alone. The new inquiries led to over 20 arrests for unrelated crimes, including a decade long unsolved murder case, but none that pertained to Abigail and Liberty. The sketch also fuelled internet sleuths, as users began sharing the image alongside photos or mug shots of men they believed
这幅画像只能作为参考，而不能视为对嫌疑人的百分之百准确还原。印第安纳州警察局中士金·莱利（Kim Riley）表示：“我们迟早会查明真相。如果这张模拟画像能帮助我们更快地找到真相，那正是我们所期望的。”画像公布后，调查人员收到了大量来自公众的信息，仅在头24小时内就涌入了1,000条线索。这些新线索导致20多人因无关罪行被捕，其中包括一桩尘封十年的未破谋杀案，但没有一条与阿比盖尔和利伯蒂有关。这张画像还助长了网络侦探的气焰，网友们开始将这张画像与他们认为是嫌疑人的男子的照片或嫌疑人档案照一起分享
matched its description. Police issued yet another plea in an effort to curtail the speculation, explaining that unfounded rumors and gossip offered no value in their investigation and only served to waste everyone's time. As the six-month anniversary of Abigail and Liberty's deaths drew near, the case was starting to languish. The 6,000 electronic billboards that had once broadcast the suspect's image across the country were no longer active, and although the total number of tips from the public had reached 24,000, the team of investigators actively working on the case dwindled. Regardless, Carroll County Sheriff Tobe Leshamby remained optimistic that the killer would be caught, telling a local news reporter, I still operate on the theory that good outweighs
警方再次发出呼吁，试图遏制这种猜测，并解释说毫无根据的谣言和八卦对他们的调查没有任何帮助，只会浪费所有人的时间。随着阿比盖尔和利伯蒂遇害六个月纪念日的临近，案件开始陷入停滞。曾经在全国各地播放嫌疑人影像的那6,000块电子广告牌已经不再活跃，尽管公众提供的线索总数已达到24,000条，但积极参与该案的调查人员队伍却在缩减。无论如何，卡罗尔县警长托比·莱尚比（Tobe Leazenby）仍然对凶手会被抓获保持乐观，他告诉当地新闻记者：“我仍然秉持着邪不压正的理论。”
evil. When Liberty's grandparents, Mike and Becky Patty, met some Indiana residents who had never heard of the case or seen the suspect's image before, they decided to front their own awareness campaign. They set to work distributing wanted posters depicting the suspect, and soon thousands were on display all over the country. Becky Patty told Indiana newspaper Journal and Courier, We are asking everyone all over the United States to help us. We want to cover the entire U.S. with this picture so he can not go into a town where there is not a flyer staring him in the face. Her husband, Mike, added, Police are not giving up and neither are we. I will spend every day of my life trying to catch this guy. I still believe someone out there knows something.
当利伯蒂的祖父母迈克和贝基·帕蒂（Mike and Becky Patty）遇到一些从未听说过该案、也从未见过嫌疑人画像的印第安纳州居民时，他们决定发起自己的宣传活动。他们着手分发描绘嫌疑人的通缉令，不久之后，成千上万张通缉令便在全国各地展示出来。贝基·帕蒂告诉印第安纳州报纸《信使报》（Journal and Courier）：“我们请求全美各地的所有人帮助我们。我们想用这张照片覆盖整个美国，这样他就无法走进一个没有传单直盯着他的面孔的小镇。”她的丈夫迈克补充道：“警方没有放弃，我们也没有。我将用我余生的每一天来试图抓住这个家伙。我依然相信外面的某个人知道些什么。”
On Monday, September 25, 2017, roughly 1000 miles west of Delphi in the state of Colorado, 31-year-old Daniel Nations and his wife, Caitlin, were pulled over by police. The red Chevrolet Prism they were driving matched descriptions of a vehicle that had been involved in a recent incident. According to witnesses, a couple in a red car had been threatening passes by with a hatchet along a trail near the Colorado town of Monument. Nations denied being involved, but a subsequent search of his car yielded a hatchet in the trunk, along with a .22 caliber semi-automatic rifle. Officers ran Daniel Nations' name through the police database and discovered he had a criminal history spanning a decade, which included convictions for public
2017年9月25日星期一，在距离德尔斐向西约1000英里的科罗拉多州，31岁的丹尼尔·内申斯（Daniel Nations）和他的妻子凯特琳（Caitlin）被警方拦下。他们驾驶的红色雪佛兰普里斯姆（Chevrolet Prism）汽车与近期发生的一起事件中涉及的车辆特征相符。据目击者称，在科罗拉多州莫纽门特（Monument）镇附近的一条小径上，一对开着红色汽车的夫妇曾挥舞手斧威胁过路人。内申斯否认参与此事，但随后对其汽车的搜查在后备箱中发现了一把手斧，以及一支.22口径半自动步枪。警官将丹尼尔·内申斯的名字输入警方数据库，发现他有长达十年的犯罪前科，其中包括在儿童面前犯下的公开
indecency, driving violations and domestic battery in the presence of a child. As a convicted felon, he was prohibited from owning a firearm and police took him into custody. Daniel Nations' arrest caught the attention of Internet sleuths, who speculated whether he could also be responsible for the murder of local cyclist Tim Watkins, who had been shot and killed on Monument Trail 10 days earlier on September 15. They also noticed that Nations bore a resemblance to the composite sketch of the unidentified suspect wanted in the double homicide of Abigail Williams and Liberty German. Like the sketch, Nations had a goatee, short hair and similar facial features, including a thin mouth, broad nose and wide-set eyes.
猥亵罪、驾驶违章和家庭殴打罪。作为一名被定罪的重罪犯，他被禁止拥有枪支，警方将其拘留。丹尼尔·内申斯的被捕引起了网络侦探的注意，他们猜测他是否也应对10天前（即9月15日）在莫纽门特步道被枪杀的当地骑自行车者蒂姆·沃特金斯（Tim Watkins）的谋杀案负责。他们还注意到，内申斯与阿比盖尔·威廉姆斯和利伯蒂·日耳曼双重谋杀案中被通缉的未知名嫌疑人的模拟画像有几分相似。就像画像一样，内申斯留着山羊胡、短发，面部特征相似，包括薄嘴唇、宽鼻子和宽眼距。
This likeness, combined with his violent criminal record and the fact he had been living in Indiana at the time of Abigail and Liberty's murders, led many to cast a suspicious eye towards Daniel Nations. On Thursday September 28, investigators from Indiana flew to Colorado to interview Nations, announcing he was the first named person of interest in the case. But the breakthrough many were hoping for never came, as he was soon ruled out as a suspect. In November the same year, 53-year-old former pastor Thomas Bruce was arrested after sexually assaulting two women and murdering a third in a Catholic supply store in Bourouin, Missouri. Like the suspect being sought for Abigail and Liberty's murders, Bruce was between five foot
这种相似性，加上他暴力的犯罪记录，以及他在阿比盖尔和利伯蒂被谋杀时曾住在印第安纳州的事实，导致许多人将怀疑的目光投向了丹尼尔·内申斯。9月28日星期四，印第安纳州的调查人员飞往科罗拉多州面审内申斯，并宣布他是本案中首个被点名的受关注人员。但许多人期盼的突破并未到来，因为他很快就被排除在嫌疑人之外。同年11月，53岁的前牧师托马斯·布鲁斯（Thomas Bruce）在密苏里州布鲁安（Bourbon）的一家天主教用品店内性侵了两名女性并谋杀第三人后被捕。就像因谋杀阿比盖尔和利伯蒂而被通缉的嫌疑人一样，布鲁斯身高在五英尺
seven and five foot nine inches tall and wore a flat cap and a navy blue jacket during the Bourouin attack. Investigators looked into the possible connection, but it led to another dead end. Similarly, 46-year-old sex offender Charles Eldridge was also compared to the sketch of Abigail and Liberty's suspected killer after being arrested in Union City, Indiana, on charges of child molestation and solicitation. But he too was promptly ruled out of the investigation. As Indiana state police continued to review and exclude persons of interest, they were forced to release a statement via social media, discouraging the public from sharing unsubstantiated theories or naming hypothetical suspects, explaining, quote,
七英寸到五英尺九英寸之间，在布鲁安袭击事件中戴着一顶扁帽和一件海蓝色夹克。调查人员调查了这种可能的联系，但它又走入了一条死胡同。同样，46岁的性犯罪者查尔斯·埃尔德里奇（Charles Eldridge）在印第安纳州联合市因猥亵儿童和拉客罪被捕后，也被拿来与阿比盖尔和利伯蒂受疑凶手的画像进行对比。但他也很快被排除在调查之外。随着印第安纳州警方继续审查并排除受关注人员，他们被迫通过社交媒体发表声明，劝阻公众不要传播毫无根据的理论或点名假设的嫌疑人，并解释说，原话是
By doing so, you take away from the investigation by slandering and possibly hurting those people and their families. Everyone is innocent until proven guilty in a court of law. If you feel someone may be the suspect, please notify the tip line. Liberty's grandfather, Mike Paddy, echoed these sentiments in a news follow-up, urging the public to leave it to the professionals to do their job. A press conference was held on the one-year anniversary of Abigail and Liberty's murders at the entrance point of the Monon Highbridge Trail. Flowers were placed at the site as Indiana state police superintendent Douglas Carter fronted attending media, praising citizens
这样做会通过诽谤和可能伤害这些人及其家人来削弱调查。在法庭被证明有罪之前，每个人都是清白的。如果你觉得某人可能是嫌疑人，请通知线索热线。利伯蒂的祖父迈克·帕蒂在随后的一篇新闻报道中呼应了这些观点，敦促公众让专业人士去做好他们的工作。在阿比盖尔和利伯蒂遇害一周年之际，在莫农高地步道的入口处举行了一场新闻发布会。鲜花被摆放在现场，印第安纳州警察局长道格拉斯·卡特（Douglas Carter）面对出席的媒体，赞扬了
across the city, state and country for the support they had provided over the past year, saying it showed the very best in humanity in the worst of times. Since the investigation had commenced, 30,000 tips had been passed on to detectives who worked to exhaust all leads in their queue. If they failed to find the answer, their plan was to start all over again. Superintendent Carter said, Our world is completely out of balance and we cannot allow evil to prevail. I refuse to accept evil as a standard bearer in American society, not here. These two young girls were everybody's daughters. He went on to explain that this was the first case where his department had both an
全市、全州乃至全国的公民在过去一年中所提供的支持，并表示这在最糟糕的时期展现了最美好的人性。自调查开展以来，已有30,000条线索传递给侦探，他们努力穷尽排队等待的所有线索。如果他们找不到答案，他们的计划就是从头再来。卡特局长说：“我们的世界完全失去了平衡，我们决不能让邪恶占上风。我拒绝接受邪恶作为美国社会的旗手，这里绝不接受。这两个年轻的女孩是每个人的女儿。”他接着解释说，这是他的部门第一次既拥有
image and voice recording of the unknown killer before claiming, I believe, where one piece of the puzzle away from figuring out who this individual is. That evening, a candlelit vigil was held in Memorial of the Slain Teens with Abigail's mother, Ranna, stating, I know people are frustrated. Nobody ever believed it would take this long and it has and we don't understand why. We're not happy about it. It would be nice for this part to be over, but it's not yet. And we will wait as long as it takes. Two months later, in May 2018, Anna travelled to Nashville, Tennessee with Liberty's grandparents Mike and Becky to attend the true crime convention, Crimecon. The trio spent the weekend speaking
未知凶手的影像又拥有声音记录的案件，随后他声称：“我相信，我们距离弄清楚这个人是谁只差最后一块拼图了。”当晚，人们为遇害的青少年举行了烛光守夜活动，阿比盖尔的母亲安娜（Anna）表示：“我知道人们感到沮丧。没有人曾经相信这会花这么长时间，但它确实发生了，我们不明白为什么。我们对此并不高兴。如果这一部分能结束就好了，但还没有。只要需要多长时间，我们就会等多久。”两个月后，即2018年5月，安娜与利伯蒂的祖父母迈克和贝基一起前往田纳西州纳什维尔，参加真实犯罪大会Crimecon。三人周末都在与
with the thousands of attendees and made an onstage appearance to discuss the case alongside Indiana State Police Sergeant Jerry Holman. Various matters that had surfaced over the course of the investigation were raised, including the prevalence of internet sleuthing. Although acknowledging these people mostly meant well, the group spoke of having been accosted by strangers intent on divulging their wild theories and of experiencing the torment of social media accusations first hand. When police initially released the sketch of the suspect, online trials claimed it looked like Mike Paddy and accused him of being his granddaughter's killer. Mike had approved an alibi for the time of the murders, but it didn't stop the hateful messages
成千上万的与会者交谈，并登台与印第安纳州警察中士杰里·霍尔曼（Jerry Holman）一起讨论该案。会上提出了调查过程中浮出水面的各种事宜，包括网络侦探的盛行。尽管承认这些人大多出于好意，但该小组成员谈到曾被意图宣扬其狂野理论的陌生人搭讪，并首当其冲地经历了社交媒体指控的折磨。当警方最初发布嫌疑人的画像时，网络审判声称它看起来像迈克·帕蒂，并指责他是他孙女的凶手。迈克已经提供了谋杀发生时的不在场证明，但这并没有阻止充满恨意的消息
or allegations leveled against him, an experience he described as heartbreaking. The panel also discussed the internet's habit of latching onto suspects who had already been cleared by investigators, stating such behavior gave the false impression that the case was solved and harmed law enforcement's ability to find the real perpetrator. Becky encouraged the audience to join a Facebook page created by the girl's families titled Brainstorming for Abbey and Libby, which instead of discussing the murders provided a space to come up with ideas to assist the progression of the investigation and bring attention to the case. Sergeant Jerry Holman would neither confirm nor deny the existence of DNA evidence,
或针对他的指控，他将这段经历描述为令人心碎。小组还讨论了互联网揪住已被调查人员排除嫌疑的人不放的习惯，并表示这种行为给人一种案件已经破获的错觉，并损害了执法部门寻找真正凶手的能力。贝基鼓励观众加入一个由女孩家人创建名为“为阿比和利比头脑风暴”（Brainstorming for Abbey and Libby）的脸书页面，该页面不讨论谋杀案，而是提供了一个提出想法以协助调查进展并引起对该案关注的空间。杰里·霍尔曼中士既不证实也不否认DNA证据的存在
but remarked, in a crime like this, very rarely do we not come up with DNA. He made it clear that despite police keeping details of the murders close to their chest, it was still a very active and high priority investigation. Like Abigail and Liberty's families, they were unwilling to give up and mark the crime as a cold case. As to what motivated the families to carry on, Mike Paddy explained, quote, the anger of the fact that Liberty's gone, that somebody's taken our girls from us. That's what drives me. I have to find this guy. I'll do whatever it takes, go to whatever place I have to go to. I'm not going to stop until we catch this guy, or I've exhausted every effort I humanly possibly can.
但评论说，在这样的犯罪中，我们极少拿不到DNA。他明确表示，尽管警方对谋杀案细节保密，但这仍然是一项非常积极且高度优先的调查。就像阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的家人一样，他们不愿意放弃并将这起犯罪归为冷案。至于是什么激励着家人们坚持下去，迈克·帕蒂解释说：“因为利伯蒂走了，有人把我们的女孩从我们身边夺走了，这种愤怒驱使着我。我必须找到这个家伙。无论付出什么代价，去到我必须去的任何地方。在抓到这个家伙之前，或者在我用尽我人力所能及的一切努力之前，我是不会停下来的。”
We owe it to our girls, our community, our state, our nation. Somebody out there knows this guy. By 2019, the second anniversary of the case came and went with no major breakthroughs. Two months later, on Monday, April 22, Superintendent Douglas Carter fronted a packed press conference delivering an emotional address to the crowd. Quote, I've got to say to the Delphi community how grateful I am. You inspire people and you don't even understand why. You did everything you could to support us, but most importantly, you surrounded the family of these two little girls. I will never forget it. He announced that police were now seeking the public's help to identify any vehicles
我们亏欠我们的女孩、我们的社区、我们的州、我们的国家。外面的某个人认识这个家伙。到了2019年，案件的两周年纪念日来来去去，却没有取得重大突破。两个月后的4月22日星期一，道格拉斯·卡特局长面对挤满人的新闻发布会，向人群发表了充满情感的演讲。“我要对德尔斐社区说，我是多么地感激。你们激励了人们，而你们甚至不明白为什么。你们尽一切所能支持我们，但最重要的是，你们环绕着这两个小女孩的家人。我永远不会忘记。”他宣布，警方现在正寻求公众的帮助，以识别任何车辆
witnessed in the parking lot of the former Department of Child Protective Services headquarters on 6931 West 300 North in Delphi. Between noon and 5 p.m. on Monday, February 13, 2017, the time Abigail and Liberty were hiking the Monon Highbridge Trail. Superintendent Carter expressed the opinion of police that the unidentified suspect either currently or previously lived or worked in Delphi or visited the area on a regular basis. In addition, he was likely aged between 18 and 40 years old, but may appear younger than his true age. He then addressed the killer directly, stating, We believe you are hiding in plain sight. For more than two years, you never thought we would
这些车辆曾在德尔斐西300北路6931号的原儿童保护服务署（Department of Child Protective Services）总部停车场被目击到。时间是在2017年2月13日星期一的中午到下午5点之间，即阿比盖尔和利伯蒂在莫农高地步道徒步的时间。卡特局长表达了警方的观点，即未识别的嫌疑人目前或曾经在德尔斐居住或工作，或者定期访问该地区。此外，他的年龄可能在18岁到40岁之间，但看起来可能比实际年龄年轻。然后，他直接向凶手喊话，称：“我们相信你正大光明地藏匿在人群中。两年多了，你从没想过我们会
shift gears to a different investigative strategy, but we have. We likely have interviewed you or someone close to you. We know that this is about power to you and you want to know what we know. And one day, you will. A question to you. What will those closest to you think when they find out that you brutally murdered two little girls, two children? Only a coward would do such a thing. We are confident that you have told someone what you have done, or at the very least, they know because how different you are since the murders. I believe you have just a little bit of conscience left. Following this statement, police unveiled a new composite sketch of the prime suspect, which looked significantly different to the original. It depicted a much younger,
转向不同的调查策略，但我们已经转向了。我们很可能已经采访过你或与你亲近的人。我们知道这关乎你的权力，你想知道我们所知道的。总有一天，你会知道的。有一个问题要问你。当你最亲近的人发现你残忍地谋杀了两名小女孩、两个孩子时，他们会怎么想？只有懦夫才会做出这种事。我们坚信你已经把你的所作所为告诉了某人，或者至少他们因为你谋杀案后的巨大改变而心知肚明。我相信你还存有一点良知。”在此声明之后，警方揭晓了主要嫌疑人的新模拟画像，该画像与最初的画像有很大不同。
clean-shaven Caucasian man with narrow facial features and short, neat, wavy hair. Unlike the original sketch, which was reportedly generated by an assortment of eyewitness descriptions, the new sketch was based on the person filmed by Liberty German. It was accompanied by the release of a silent two-second video excerpt of the footage, showing the suspect in motion as he walked along the bridge with his head down and hands in his pockets. An updated audio clip of him speaking was also released. In the extended audio file, he can be heard saying the word guise at the outset of the previously released snippet, Down the Hill. Some members of Delphi's community were rattled by the possibility the murderer may be among them.
描绘的是一个年轻得多、刮得光溜溜的白人男子，五官狭窄，留着短短、整齐的波浪发。与据称由各种目击者描述拼凑而成的最初画像不同，新画像是根据利伯蒂·日耳曼拍摄的人制作的。伴随发布的还有该视频的一个两秒钟无声剪辑片段，展示了嫌疑人在桥上低着头、双手插兜行走时的动态。同时还发布了他说话的更新音频剪辑。在扩展的音频文件中，可以听到他在先前发布的片段开头说出了“guys”（伙计们）这个词，即“Down the Hill”（下山）。德尔斐社区的一些成员对凶手可能就在他们中间这种可能性感到不安。
Others were not as surprised, having long concluded the killer must have some level of familiarity with the area, as the Monon High Bridge was not a location an outsider could easily stumble across. As with the release of the first sketch, the second also led to an influx of amateur sleuthing. On Tuesday, April 30, the Carroll County Sheriff's Office posted a message on their Facebook page, which read, Please stop posting side-by-side pictures of people you think did this. You are ruining innocent people's lives. Before posting a side-by-side, imagine that is your son, brother, or father. By the end of May 2019, police had received 4,000 new tips, with Superintendent Douglas Carter telling ABC News reporters that they needed just one final piece of information to
其他人则没有那么惊讶，他们早就断定凶手对该地区必须有一定程度的熟悉，因为莫农高桥并不是外人可以轻易偶然发现的地方。与第一张画像发布时一样，第二张画像也引来了大量业余侦探。4月30日星期二，卡罗尔县警长办公室在他们的脸书主页上发布了一条消息，上面写着：“请停止发布你认为做了这件事的人的并排对比照片。你正在毁掉无辜人们的生活。在发布并排对比照片之前，请想象那是你的儿子、兄弟或父亲。”到2019年5月底，警方已经收到了4,000条新线索，道格拉斯·卡特局长对美国广播公司新闻（ABC News）记者表示，他们只需要最后一条信息就能
solve the case, and were, quote, one tip away from success. He believed there was someone acquainted with the killer, or who knew a crucial detail, but was too afraid to come forward. In the two-and-a-half years since Abigail Williams and Liberty German were murdered, the reward for information that leads to an arrest has increased to $240,000. The loss continues to impact the Delphi community, with small things serving as a constant reminder of the tragedy. Posters of the two best friends are still displayed in the windows of local businesses, who vow to keep them there until the suspect is apprehended. In response to a request from the teen's families, porch lights throughout town now glisten orange, and the
破案，并且“距离成功只有一条线索之遥”。他相信有人与凶手相识，或者知道一个至关重要的细节，但因过于害怕而不敢站出来。在阿比盖尔·威廉姆斯和利伯蒂·日耳曼被谋杀后的两年半里，提供破案线索的悬赏金已经增加到了24万美元。这种损失继续冲击着德尔斐社区，一些微小的事物成了这场悲剧的不断提醒。两个最好朋友的海报仍然贴在当地企业的橱窗里，他们发誓要一直留在那里，直到嫌疑人被捕。为了响应少女家人们的请求，全镇的门廊灯现在都闪烁着橙色，并且
lampposts that border the Carroll County Courthouse Square are still tied with ribbons in the girl's favorite colors, teal and purple, to remind the townspeople that justice is yet to be served. When Abigail and Liberty's families first started receiving donations from supporters around the country, they considered using the money to purchase new equipment for the softball field where the girls had played together. But as the funds steadily increased, the family set their sights higher, and by mid-2019, construction had begun on the Abbey and Libby Memorial Park, an outdoor recreation area for Delphi residents to appreciate nature, art, and sport for generations to come. Built on a conspicuous 21-acre lot at the southeast
沿卡罗尔县法院广场边缘的路灯仍然系着女孩们最喜欢的颜色——蓝绿色和紫色的缎带，以提醒镇民正义尚未得到伸张。当阿比盖尔和利伯蒂的家人首次开始收到来自全国各地支持者的捐款时，他们曾考虑用这笔钱为女孩们一起玩过垒球场购买新设备。但随着资金稳步增加，家人们把目光放得更高，到2019年中期，“阿比和利比纪念公园”（Abbey and Libby Memorial Park）已经开始动工，这是一个供德尔斐居民世世代代欣赏自然、艺术和体育的户外休闲区。建在一个显眼的21英亩地块上，位于东南角
corner of the Hoosier Heartland Highway and Indiana State Road 218, upon its completion, the Abbey and Libby Memorial Park will incorporate three softball fields, an amphitheater, two playgrounds, and a walking trail. In preparation for construction, Liberty's grandfather Mike Paddy used a backhoe to begin clearing the land himself, telling a local newspaper, it will be a tribute to those girls long, long after I'm gone. I'm not resting until that happens. In addition to assisting with the Memorial Park's development, Anna Williams has taken up a cause that was close to her daughter's heart. Abigail had been passionate about helping those less fortunate, and one of her favorite projects was putting together care packages
即胡希尔心脏地带高速公路（Hoosier Heartland Highway）和印第安纳州218号公路的交汇处，建成后，阿比和利比纪念公园将包含三个垒球场、一个露天剧场、两个游乐场和一条步行小径。在为建设做准备时，利伯蒂的祖父迈克·帕蒂亲自用反铲挖土机开始清理土地，他告诉当地一家报纸：“在我离去很久很久之后，这将是对这些女孩的致敬。在事情办成之前，我是不会歇息的。”除了协助纪念公园的开发外，安娜·威廉姆斯还承担了一项贴近她女儿内心的事业。阿比盖尔一直热衷于帮助那些不幸的人，她最喜欢的项目之一就是整理爱心包裹
for children in need. She would fill shoeboxes with school supplies and personal hygiene products, then send them to charities that worked with disadvantaged overseas communities. Anna has since created Abbey's Angels to carry on her daughter's tradition. Each year in the lead-up to Christmas, she bands together with students from Delphi Community Middle School and other members of the community to organize parcels to send to charities in Abigail's name. Anna told a reporter that she feels her daughter's presence with her as she does so. Quote, this was something that was really important to Abbey. She loved this project. It was something we looked forward to doing together, and I'm glad that we're still
送给有需要的儿童。她会把鞋盒塞满学校用品和个人卫生用品，然后把它们寄给与海外弱势社区合作的慈善机构。此后，安娜创立了“阿比的天使”（Abbey's Angels），以继承她女儿的传统。每年圣诞节前夕，她都会与德尔斐社区中学的学生以及社区的其他成员联合起来，组织包裹以阿比盖尔的名义寄给慈善机构。安娜告诉记者，她在这样做时感到女儿就在她身边。“原话是，这对阿比来说是一件非常重要的事情。她热爱这个项目。这是我们期待一起做的事情，我很高兴我们仍然在
doing it in her honor. Liberty's older sister Kelsey German does anything to keep her sister's story in the public consciousness, speaking candidly to reporters and podcasters often, while making appearances at true crime conventions and campaigning via her Twitter account, at LibertyG underscore sister. A tattoo of Liberty's name etched onto her back pays tribute to her younger sister and is accompanied by the words, I can't see you, but I can feel you. Liberty's brave decision to record the suspect on her smartphone has since helped others facing their own threats. During the family's 2018 Crimecon appearance, an audience member informed the panel that his niece was attacked in a park, and because she was aware of Liberty
以她的名义做这件事。”利伯蒂的姐姐凯尔西·日耳曼（Kelsey German）为了让妹妹的故事留在公众的意识中，愿意做任何事情，她经常坦率地对记者和播客发言，同时在真实犯罪大会上露面，并通过她的推特账号@LibertyG_sister进行竞选活动。刻在她背上的利伯蒂名字的纹身向她的妹妹致敬，并伴随着这样一句话：“我看不见你，但我能感觉到你。”利伯蒂在智能手机上记录下嫌疑人的勇敢决定，自那以后帮助了其他面临自身威胁的人。在2018年Crimecon大会期间，一位观众向小组成员透露，他的侄女在公园遭到袭击，正因为她了解利伯蒂
German's actions, had the foresight to record evidence on her phone, which ultimately led to the capture and prosecution of her perpetrator. Liberty's grandparents run an official news information website titled abbeyandlibi.org, where you can find up to date credible information on the case. Anyone with information regarding the unsolved murders of Abigail Williams and Liberty German in Delphi, Indiana on Monday, February 13, 2017, is encouraged to send an email to the Carroll County Sheriff's Department using abbeyandlibi-tip at cacoshrf.com, or to call the FBI phone tip line on 844-459-5786. An inscription on Liberty's gravestone reads, The Lord took you on a February day to a wonderful place so far away. Not a day goes by we don't
日耳曼的行为，才有先见之明地在手机上记录了证据，这最终导致了对袭击者的抓捕和起诉。利伯蒂的祖父母经营着一个名为abbeyandlibi.org的官方新闻信息网站，在那里你可以找到关于该案的最新可靠信息。任何掌握有关2017年2月13日星期一在印第安纳州德尔斐发生的阿比盖尔·威廉姆斯和利伯蒂·日耳曼未破谋杀案相关信息的人，都被鼓励使用abbeyandlibi-tip@cacoshrf.com向卡罗尔县治安官办公室发送电子邮件，或拨打FBI电话线844-459-5786。利伯蒂墓碑上的铭文写着：“主在一个二月天把你带走，带去了那个无比美妙的远方。没有一天我们不在
cry for you, although we know you would not want us to. Our hearts will heal, our thoughts will clear, but in our hearts will keep you near. For God has welcomed you with open arms, with his love, and without any more harm. We'll keep your memories in our minds, but happiness without you is awful hard to find. You will always be a blessing no one can replace our love for you, but living without you is the hardest thing we do. We'll wipe our tears for you in a better place, and keep our memories of you that no one can erase. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
为你哭泣，尽管我们知道你并不希望我们如此。我们的心会治愈，我们的思绪会理清，但我们会将你紧紧锁在心中。因为上帝已经张开双臂、带着他的爱、不再让你受到任何伤害地迎候了你。我们会将你的记忆印在脑海，但没有你的幸福却那么难找。你永远是无人能替代的祝福，我们对你的爱始终如一，但没有你的生活是我们做过最难的事。我们在一个更好的地方为你拭去泪水，并将对你的记忆永远珍藏，无人能抹去。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。